en este vídeo quiero introducirlos a la
idea de una lista de las listas en
python es una de las estructuras más
poderosas en python y en realidad es una
secuencia de cosas una lista en python
una lista de enteros sería algo así 17
negativo
y 10 podríamos tener una variable que se
refiere a esta lista lo vamos a ver más
tarde en un programa así que digamos que
a es igual a todo esto si queremos esto
en un intérprete o si corremos esto en
un programa podríamos referirnos a los
elementos de a y lo podríamos hacer de
la siguiente manera tenemos a lo hacemos
refiriéndonos al índice de los elementos
dentro de la lista entonces si tengo a y
en corchetes pongo un cero esto indica
el elemento cero de a y como una
convención general en python y en muchos
lenguajes de programación se considera
al primer elemento de un arreglo o de
una lista como el elemento 0 o sea el
índice de este elemento es 0 así que si
tecleamos esto en un intérprete o si
tenemos esto en un programa el elemento
índice 0 sería evaluado como este
elemento de aquí el elemento 0 es este
uno dejen hacer otro ejemplo el segundo
elemento de a sería
elemento 0 primer elemento segundo
elemento sería este 0 de aquí entonces
aquí tenemos todos los elementos de
nuestra lista y probablemente han
imaginado las cosas interesantes que se
pueden hacer con esto pero lo que es
realmente padre de las listas es que no
tienen que ser del mismo tipo de datos
las listas pueden ser de enteros de
decimales de cadenas de caracteres
strings pero también se pueden mezclar
los tipos de datos así que tenemos la
lista a y podríamos redefinir uno de sus
elementos decimos a redefinimos el
cuarto elemento de a el cuarto elemento
de a es igual a este texto literalmente
este texto y si hacemos esto y le
decimos al programa imprime a print y
entonces se vería de esta manera el
elemento 0 no cambió sigue siendo 1 el
primer elemento sigue siendo un 7
negativo el elemento indexado número 2
seguirá siendo 0
este sería el tercero aquí tenemos el
índice 0 1º 2º 3º 4º y reemplazamos el
cuarto elemento que ahora es este texto
ahora es este texto esto es algo que
probaremos con el intérprete de payton y
el último elemento seguirá siendo 10
todo esto es completamente válido se
puede hacer en python se pueden mezclar
diferentes tipos de datos y después de
hacer esto podríamos decir que podríamos
redefinir el índice 0 dea y decir que es
otra lista podríamos decir que es la
lista 1 negativo 2 negativo y si hacemos
esto el elemento 0 que está aquí ahora
estará apuntando a la otra lista así que
la nueva lista se vería de la siguiente
manera el primer elemento mejor dicho el
elemento 0 ahora sería 1 negativo 2
negativo y después tenemos 7 negativo
pero este texto
y al final el 10 justo así si definimos
el elemento 0 de esta manera ahora
estará apuntando a esta estructura de
datos y probablemente ya habrán
imaginado una gran cantidad de formas de
usar esto en los programas bueno si no
lo han hecho no se preocupen ya
estaremos viendo muchas maneras de
usarlo hay algo que quiero dejar muy
claro digamos que tenemos una lista que
está definida por b y que sus elementos
son 7 7 13 15 esta es mi lista y digamos
que la siguiente línea de mi programa es
si estoy usando el intérprete de payton
la siguiente línea es c es igual a b y
algunas veces ustedes van a querer hacer
esto quiero una copia debe y lo que
quiero dejar claro es que ese y b están
apuntando a la misma cosa se están
refiriendo a la misma cosa así que si
quieren imaginar qué está sucediendo
aquí hay alguna entidad en la memoria de
la computadora que se ve así
13 15 y cuando ejecutan esta instrucción
esta primera instrucción ve
definitivamente está apuntando a esto la
variable be se refiere a esta entidad y
cuando decimos se es igual a b realmente
estamos diciendo que se está apuntando a
esta misma cosa a la que ve se está
refiriendo se no es una copia no hacemos
una copia hacemos que se apunte a esta
misma entidad y lo que es relevante aquí
es que si ahora cambiamos o mejor dicho
si cambiamos lo que se está apuntando
vamos a cambiar también lo que ve está
apuntando se los mostraré en un momento
con el intérprete pero ahora déjenme
explicar un poco más esto que les digo
en este punto diremos el elemento 0 de c
lo hacemos igual a 1 y como les dije
antes si imprimimos decimos prince
obtendremos lo siguiente 1
13 y 15 y si decimos imprime be green
bay también obtendremos 1 13 y 15 y esto
es porque el color de aquí o porque la
instrucción que está aquí cambia el
elemento 0 de la lista a la que se está
refiriendo oa la que está apuntando así
que ya no es más 7 sino que ahora es 1
así que si tenemos el elemento 0 debe
ser a un 1 y no un 7 podrían decir ok
entiendo esto que si hago una variable
igual a otra variable que apunta a una
lista lo que realmente estoy haciendo es
apuntar a la misma lista y que si cambio
uno de los elementos de la lista lo que
realmente estoy cambiando es la entidad
a la que está apuntando entonces como
podría copiar una lista cómo podría
realmente copiar una lista de escribir y
aquí si realmente quieren copiar lo que
deben hacer es lo siguiente escribiremos
c es igual a b y probablemente les
parezca chistoso pero deben escribir
estos dos puntos aquí dentro y lo que
esto hace es copiar
significa copiar todo lo que está en ve
desde el principio hasta el final pero
también podrían decir que es igual a ve
desde cero hasta el segundo elemento
pero sin incluirlo hasta el segundo
elemento sin incluirlo así que esto va a
crear una nueva lista que tendrá el
elemento cero y el primer elemento y no
va a incluir el segundo elemento en este
caso lo que hacemos con esta cosa de
aquí es crear una nueva lista que se ve
así si asumimos que tenemos la lista
definida de esta manera esto creará una
nueva lista como esta y ahora se apunta
a esta nueva lista que se refiere a esta
nueva lista con esto se creó una copia
de los primeros dos elementos el
elemento 0 y el primer elemento sin
incluir el segundo elemento si quieren
incluir el segundo elemento tendrían que
poner 3 aquí si quieren copiar todos los
elementos de la lista hacen esto qué
significa copiar todos los elementos
desde el principio hasta el final
crearía una lista separada que sería al
igual que ve pero sería otra lista y si
ahora apunta a esta lista y ahora si
cambiamos ce no vamos a cambiar be bueno
ya fue suficiente de sólo hablar de esto
vamos a jugar con nuestro intérprete
porque esta es la parte divertida voy a
quitar este texto de aquí para que no se
vayan a confundir definamos la lista a
es igual a 12 déjenme escribirlo de esta
manera 12 7 negativo 9 11 defina esta
lista y la verifico imprimiendo va print
a la pueden ver aquí podemos cambiar uno
de los elementos de a digamos que vamos
a cambiar el primer elemento recuerden
que cuando hablamos de índices el primer
elemento no es este este es el elemento
cero así que estaremos cambiando este de
aquí y sólo por diversión cambiamos este
elemento a un string digamos
el texto
y ahora veamos cómo se ve vamos a
imprimir a print
así que fíjense tomó el primer elemento
este es el elemento cero este es el
primer elemento y lo cambio por nuestro
texto y lo podemos ver aquí ahora
hagamos algo interesante digamos que ve
es igual a imprimimos ve decimos print
ve y se ve igual que a dejen hacer otra
cosa déjenme hacer se es igual a a y
entonces hagamos lo que expliqué
anteriormente hagamos una copia de a
vamos a imprimirse print si entonces
tenemos que ver si se ven de la misma
manera pero son dos cosas diferentes se
es una copia de a o se es una copia de
lo que a está apuntando y ve está
apuntando a la misma cosa que a está
apuntando y para comprobarlo vamos a
cambiar el primer elemento debe y dice
vamos a hacer el primer elemento debe
igual a cero y ahora imprimimos ve vemos
que el primer elemento es cero y lo que
también podemos
es que si imprimimos el primer elemento
también es un cero porque ahí ve están
apuntando a la misma cosa esto significa
que a cualquier cosa que esté apuntando
si le cambiamos el elemento cero y lo
hacemos igual a cero como a está
apuntando a la misma lista
el elemento cero de a también será cero
pero se está apuntando a una copia dea
así que se no ha cambiado el elemento
cero de aquí no cambio así que las
listas son súper poderosas
hay muchas funciones que se pueden usar
con las listas y les he mostrado un poco
aquí tenemos a podemos añadir elementos
a decimos a punto a pent y podemos
añadir algo al final de a podríamos
añadir un elemento nuevo elemento nuevo
y si lo hacen se añadirá al final de a
así que veamos a añadió el elemento
nuevo al final como ve está apuntando a
la misma cosa vamos a ver cómo se ve y
se es una copia de la definición
anterior de
así que veamos cómo cbc seno tiene el
elemento nuevo al final porque no se
añadió a la copia solo se añadió a lo
que estaba apuntando anteriormente y que
es la misma cosa que ve y hay muchísimas
funciones muy útiles que exploraremos en
tanto que hacemos más y más programas
más y más ejemplos de programas y hay
muchas funciones en las que las listas
pueden ser manipuladas y cambiadas de
diferentes maneras